jetzt kommen wir zu einem total ihren
fall das habe ich noch nie gehört eine
vielleicht neue dimension das thema ist
corona eine solche oder nicht also klar
jeder würde sagen natürlich solle eine
solche firma immer in den nachrichten
hören wir auch bei bild.de aber es gibt
einen total ihren fall aus der nähe von
münchen
da hat ein unternehmer geglaubt er hat
eine versicherung gegen solche solchen
abgeschlossen hatte auch aber was dann
dabei heraus gekommen ist will er uns
selbst erzählen
stefan olschewski müsste in der leitung
sein hören sie uns ja hallo erzählen sie
doch mal von diesem irren fall sie haben
eine versicherung mit einem sehr
komplizierten namen abgeschlossen
und wie geht es weiter
das ging dann so weiter und jetzt in der
oper betriebshaftpflichtversicherung
drin das ist das infektionsschutzgesetz
und dieses gesetz besagt eben da gibt es
eine liste davon welche krankheiten
darin versichert sind wir haben dann
festgestellt dass carola also nicht da
drin ist haben aber dann auch gleich
nachgefragt
deutschen bundestag und so weiter ein
gesundheitsämtern warum das nicht drin
ist wir hatten dann aber auch prompt
eine information bekommen dass dieses
corona virus wie immer man es nennen mag
ab 12 dieses jahres in die liste mit
aufgenommen wurde
das problem allerdings es wurden am ende
die meldepflicht ausgedient und nicht
ein gesetz erlassen dass dieses jetzt in
dieser liste steht also vom bundesrat
möchte das gesetz erlassen werden dass
die korona virus in die liste
aufgenommen wird
klingt etwas kompliziert ich sage es
nochmal also sie haben eine versicherung
die sie aus startet mit dem schutz wenn
zum beispiel eine solche durch
deutschland rast dass sie dann geld
bekommen und möglicherweise ihren
gaststätten und hotelbetrieb retten
können aber offiziell und dass es dann
halt die geschichte des kleingedruckten
ist corona da noch nicht als offizielle
solche anerkannt ich habe gehört sie
haben auch mittlerweile eine absage von
der generali versicherung bekommen also
die sind nicht bereit jetzt dafür gerade
zu stehen ist das der letzte stand das
ist jetzt gerade der schrank stand
gestern
sie haben also definitiv abgesagt da sie
das nicht versichern und natürlich diese
wortklauberei ist natürlich etwas sehr
ärgerlich weil in dem moment wir zahlen
ja auch bestimmte gebühren dafür und die
versicherungsprämien uns wir halten dich
sehr geholfen das würde nämlich alles
abdecken was zumindest die laufenden
kosten an pacht gehälter und so weiter
gehen wie geht es mit ihnen weiter sie
haben glaube ich hilfen auch schon
beantragt aber was passiert wenn
generale
dabei bleibt und nicht zahlt was macht
das mit ihrem betrieb na ja was macht
ihr betrieb wir müssen durchhalten
auch diese zuschüsse die soforthilfen
und sagen wir mal 7000 9000 über 15.000
euro das ist ja mal ganz nett ist ein
kosten einen tropfen auf dem heißen
stein
wir werden sehen wie das weitergeht
überhaupt kein thema wenn man natürlich
wohnkosten den wundert hat uni wagen
einkauf über 28.000 euro an gehältern gc
und pacht wird man sich gedanken machen
müssen
ich rede natürlich mit den banken die
wollen natürlich wieder einen kredit
geben oder die machen einen
überziehungskredit natürlich zu
horrenden zinsen muss man auch dazu
sagen aber so könnte man sich über
wasser halten
ich wünsche ihnen dabei alles gute und
zum abschluss haben wir natürlich auch
vielleicht noch jemand da der kann sich
da mal drum kümmern an kempkens wie ist
das ärger mit versicherung immer nervig
muss man da klein beigeben oder lohnt es
tatsächlich dagegen vorzugehen nenne da
wollen wir doch mal sehen wie das
ausgeht
ich meine das ist ja hier ein risiko was
versichert war und mit das ist meistens
so relativ günstig mit versichert worden
weil man gar nicht davon ausgegangen ist
dass das zu einer ja in so eine riesen
schaden verursachen könnte so und jetzt
geht es bei diesem
versicherungsbedingungen immer um die
frage wie sind die dann auszulegen den
versicherungsbedingungen sind nicht
auszulegen wie ich jetzt als fachmann
das sehen würde sondern auszulegen wie
der durchschnittliche
versicherungsnehmer das versteht so und
danach sind die auszulegen ganz
spannendes feld und dann müssen wir mal
sehen ob wir diese diese corona aircargo
nicht in diese verträge noch betreiben
bekommen mit der folge dass ist
natürlich trotz dieser problematik die
gerade geschildert worden ist trotzdem
ein versicherungsfall ist ich bin sehr
gespannt es wird ein heißer kampf ja
vielen dank das sind doch schon mal ganz
gute nachrichten vielleicht herr
olschewski ist noch nicht alles verloren
wir bleiben da auf jeden fall dran ich
habe selbst wir haben jetzt kontakt
aufgenommen mit generale haben gefragt
wie kann das sein
das sind wirklich wortklaubereien das
ist möglicherweise auch eine masche da
versucht man sich rauszureden das ist
halt wieder mal zu lasten der
versicherungsnehmer die wirklich
monatelang oder jahre lang beiträge
bezahlen
die generali versicherung hat nur sehr
allgemein geantwortet scheint da noch
nicht so ganz klar stellung zu beziehen
klar die absage jetzt an herrn
olschewski war auch ein klares zeichen
und das sind wirklich noch mein appell
liebe manager von generali das kann ja
wohl nicht sein das ist jetzt der
allererste fall dass wirklich ein
unternehmer jetzt mal diese versicherung
ziehen muss und dann heißt es corona ist
irgendwie noch gar keine solche also
liebe manager überlegen sie noch einmal
wollen sie diese namen gastwirt wirklich
nichts gutes tun das ist wirklich
wichtig dass da geholfen wird und
wortklaubereien bringen einen da
wirklich nicht weiter und bevor ich mich
noch weiter aufreger ist findet sich ein
unglaubliches thema verabschiede ich
mich bedanke mich noch mal bei meinen
gästen und freue mich auf die nächste
sendung alles gute bleiben sie gesund
ihre neuer spar fox